- [Mark] All right, Tiffani.
Tiffani, where did you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Tiffani] I'm from Baltimore, Maryland.
- [Mark] Baltimore?
- [Tiffani] Mm-hmm.
- And tell me about your childhood.
You had both of your parents growing up?
- No, my mom died when I was a baby
and my dad, he lives in New York,
and I only met him once.
I think I was eight
years old, when I met him
and ever since then, I
never heard from him.
- [Mark] How did you lose your mom?
- She died from a heroin overdose.
- [Mark] Oh, wow.
So you ended up being raised by who?
- My grandmother.
- [Mark] How was childhood?
- Well,
it was okay I guess, growing up.
But I used to get in a lot of fights
since elementary school,
and as I was growing up,
at the age of 13 I think,
if I'm not mistaken,
if my memory serves me correctly,
I got on a party line
and I met this guy that was 29 years old
on a party line,
and I got caught in my
grandma's basement with him,
but I didn't do anything
with him at the time
because I ended up falling asleep
and he did too,
and I got caught by my aunt's husband.
They ended up calling the police
and I ended up going to the hospital
because they wanted to make sure
nothing was wrong with me or whatever.
But I never did anything with the guy,
and I got in trouble for that,
so they called my
grandmother
out here,
to come get me.
And she came from out here.
- [Mark] So you were living where?
- In Baltimore, Maryland.
- [Mark] In Baltimore, okay.
Could we put the mask away?
Just put it in your pocket, or...
There you go.
And what kind of kid
were you in high school?
- I was so far a good kid,
until like my 10th grade year.
I got in trouble again,
for getting on a party line,
me and another guy.
And I just got put on punishment,
got my cellphone taken, I believe.
It was nothing serious like that,
but pretty much, yeah.
It's hot in here, no lie.
- [Mark] Sorry.
No AC.
So you started working in
the street at what age?
- 16.
- [Mark] And this was in Baltimore?
- Uh, no.
Out here.
- [Mark] Oh, you moved out here.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Okay.
And that was with a pimp or by yourself?
- I was by myself.
- [Mark] How did that go?
Do you remember your first time?
- Um, yeah I do.
I was with this Mexican guy.
It was actually one of
my friends, her dad.
I dated him or whatever, like...
He took me to his house
or his wife's house
and he gave me some money,
some weed or whatever,
and we had sex.
And then he dropped me
off at my grandma's house.
- [Mark] You're-
- And to this day, he
still, I still call him.
He still sees me, but we don't do anything
because he's older.
He's like way older now, so like,
he's kind of sick, you know?
- [Mark] So did that open up the...
Open up your mind to doing this?
- Yeah, fast money.
- [Mark] Fast money.
- Easy.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Is there any other job you could get
that would compete money-wise for this?
(clicks tongue)
- Well, I don't know
because I've had plenty jobs,
and I feel that me standing at work,
for all these hours
for a little bit of nothing
is like a waste of time,
when I could stand on a
corner for five minutes.
As soon as I step on the concrete,
I'm catching a date for like 300, 700.
It just all depends.
- [Mark] Yeah, and you
get addicted to that.
- Yes, I'm addicted to it.
- [Mark] Are you using drugs as well?
- [Tiffani] Sometimes.
(sirens blaring faintly)
- [Mark] You've had bad
experiences doing this?
- [Tiffani] Um, honestly,
No.
- [Mark] Guys haven't been rough with you
when they pick you up
or rob you or anything like that?
- [Tiffani] Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That happens all the time.
(Mark laughs)
Actually, I just recently got robbed.
Just for $1100.
(sirens continue)
It's sad, but I did,
like probably three weeks ago.
- [Mark] You've been arrested before?
- [Tiffani] Plenty of times.
I just got out of prison
probably about, like, 11 months ago.
The federal prison.
- [Mark] What was that for?
- [Tiffani] Uh, that was
just for a violation.
- [Mark] Because
prostitution in California
doesn't really get you prison time.
- [Tiffani] No.
I went to the feds
for some other .... that I used to do.
But I'm off probation on that .... now,
so I don't have to worry about that.
- [Mark] Do you have kids?
- Um, yes.
I have one son.
- [Mark] Are you raising him?
- No.
- [Mark] Who is he with?
- Right now he's somewhere,
because he has an
aggressive behavior problem,
so they're trying to figure out
what is really going on with him,
why he's acting out the way he is.
Of course, because he
misses me and he needs me,
but other reasons why.
- [Mark] Would it be possible
that you turn towards me a little bit?
There you go, awesome.
Does this lifestyle get
you depressed sometimes?
Do you get down?
- Yeah, sometimes.
I need some water.
- [Mark] We'll get you a water.
Hold on a second.
- Please.
- [Mark] So I just asked you
if you get depressed sometimes.
Is that always-
- I'm depressed all the time,
to tell you the truth.
Honestly speaking,
I'm depressed all the time.
- [Mark] What do you think gets you down,
just this lifestyle is...?
- Not pretty much the lifestyle.
Well, sometimes yeah,
but just the fact that
(Tiffani sighs)
I'm a single mother.
I'm out here on the streets doing this.
I don't have a stable place to stay.
I'm dependent on a nigga
who I'm really not that
sure gives a ... about me,
so, um,
I don't know.
- [Mark] Are you saving money at all?
- Well, yeah I am.
I'm not saving it.
I don't have it in my possession,
but I believe there's
money being saved, I guess.
- [Mark] What do you think
the most misunderstood thing
about girls that do this for a living is,
from outside,
for people that don't know?
- What do I think about what?
- [Mark] What do you think the
most misunderstood thing...
People drive down Figueroa
and they'll see girls working the street,
and just think, "Oh these..."
- Yeah, you know what?
There's been plenty of times
where I've said, like,
"Damn, a b...," excuse my French,
"can't even walk down Figueroa
without a person stereotyping them
thinking that they're a prostitute."
How come I can't just be a regular girl
and walk to the store,
or whatever the case may be?
Why do I have to be a ho?
But, 99% of the time,
you're a ho.
(Tiffani chuckles)
- [Mark] Any girl in a short
skirt on Figueroa is...
- Yeah.
Throw a wig on a pig.
(Tiffani chuckles)
- [Mark] ...is doing business.
What was the best time of your life?
- The best time of my life that I had,
when I had my son.
But so far after that, it's just,
I see myself going downhill.
It's like a repeating pattern
that I keep doing,
and either I'm going to get it together
or I'm just gonna forever be
doing this street sh...
- [Mark] Yep, how old are you now?
- I'm old.
I'm 29.
- [Mark] You're young.
- I'm old.
I shouldn't be doing this at this age.
- [Mark] Well, no one should be doing this
at any age.
- Yeah, yeah, any age, but...
I'm done with it already.
I should be, but hey, the money's good.
I gotta win.
- [Mark] How do you think doing this for,
for 14 years of your life has changed you?
(Tiffani sighs)
- Well, mentally, it hasn't changed me.
Physically, I just lost some weight
to try to look good,
but I don't think it's changed me.
It's just made me more of a boss b
and a go-getter.
- [Mark] Do you think you'll ever
be able to walk away from this?
- Will I ever?
- [Mark] Yeah, will you be able to?
- Yeah.
Most definitely.
- [Mark] It sounds like you can stand back
and look at what you're doing
and see the craziness in it, right?
- Yeah.
The ... I had to go through,
putting up with these tricks,
b...., wasting time.
Like, yeah.
Was it all worth it?
That's the question.
- [Mark] Do you think doing this has also
changed the way you view men?
- Yes, most definitely.
Especially the married
men, the married men.
- I'll bet you a lot of your
customers are married, right?
- Yeah.
Married, of course. Yeah.
Or they either just got
out of a relationship
or they're not happy at home
so they want to go out on
the streets and find a girl.
- [Mark] Yeah.
A lot of the guys are addicted...
- Yeah.
- [Mark] ...to it as well.
- Sometimes it just be
their fetish, I guess.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Have you been in love before?
- Yeah.
Does doing this get in the
way of those relationships?
- No, because I'm not in a
relationship, relationship
like that.
I mean, like, my n...
that I'm with, like...
I don't know.
It's kind of weird, but, I love him.
But I'm not in love with him.
I love him like I've got love for him.
He's been there for me.
He's helped me.
He's put up with me.
I'm his headache.
And I'm not going anywhere.
- [Mark] Do you think if your mom,
if you hadn't lost your
mom at an early age,
your life would be different?
- Yeah, probably so.
Probably so.
- [Mark] What advice would you give
to a young girl who is
considering doing this?
- Well, my advice would be,
if you're going to do it,
just make sure that you protect yourself,
because the streets don't love nobody,
and, you just gotta be careful.
You can't trust everybody.
Us black women we're queens
and we should stand tall
for ourselves and not look
at ourselves as nothing
because this is nothing,
walking the streets,
selling our bodies,
like anything can happen
we could die, get raped, get kidnapped
and anything
living this lifestyle,
I feel like this is the
risk that I'm taking like
I could die anyday, getting in cars
with these tricks, I don't know
I've been through some s... low key
I just never say anything to nobody
- [Mark] All right Tiffani,
thank you so much for sharing your story
- Thank you
- [Mark] Good luck with wherever you go.